how do you say egg in Japanese oh my god
tamago together
tamago tamago tamago tamago tamago
alright today I'm with the Japan we're
gonna be trying three delicious egg
dishes at three vastly different price
points to find out which egg it's the
most worth its price we went to a local
convenience store you got a bunch of egg
snacks because I have effect for you
imma go mama Dookie on average Japanese
people III hundred and twenty eggs per
year making them the third highest
consumers of eggs Wow
you know what into let me guess China
your clothes Korea no India no Malaysia
what and Mexico I'm so mad at myself
we have a delicious egg salad sandwich
single serving hard-boiled egg this egg
salad sandwich that is a pizza on top
yeah and a sandwich has two our bold egg
halves in it depending on us how about
the best one
no I did you will get the pizza one this
is a really good first stop we're going
to the Tsukiji fish market let's go
coverage on my route aqui - oh no he
Tony Soto my give up your mascot is one
of the coolest I've ever seen
can you tell me the story behind it oh
there they usually might just donate
toys tortillas and I take it off like I
took a corner like that you might even a
Kincaid a high tempo todo o Yanna
between some Calabasas no yo Maximus day
no Joe cada Amaya a Kieran's Hakeem
associate could start a cure that's me
Nicholas my kid
Santa you know buddy I did so today
where's the cumbia day yeah I told you
Matthew what do you think is so great
about eggs - yes ma a.m. my
ee-yaa-ee-yaa-ee-o start on those EBC oh
hey
yes hi guys it soon a I do you eat the
tamagoyaki everyday feminism as you know
I do my mascara
oh here the marginal Cara like up to
kanji that's me oh you know bank you're
here effort thank you very much we're at
this Tsukiji fish market and it's been a
bucket list item for me for a long time
did you think you'd be coming here to
eat eggs no ho which is the crazy thing
get a little souvenir while I wasn't
looking as soon as the interview cut the
owner pulled this out and just and to me
is like you're gonna want this and now
it's now I shouldn't be because I'm
about to eat this delicious omelet this
is the one dollar slice that you can get
a delicate golden finish to it like
creme brulee but the size of a Twinkie
like butter you do talky moss I get mine
oh wow oh wow I actually did not expect
a flavor that came from this sweetness
yeah but still savory it's almost like a
soy honey glaze you get on a chicken
wing I think the best part of this egg
for me is the texture I'm chewing it
with my tongue all right because I don't
so I can get maximum flavor almost first
a little bit you know caviar it's very
juicy with the added sweetness the touch
of savoriness this is very much like a
little slice of cake it will be fitting
that eggs aren't such a large component
of cake this could be dessert it could
also be a meal mm-hmm I want to eat this
whole thing
yucky mas
good thing you ate the rest of it right
there what do you think about their
automation their system they have here
it's an assembly line but everything
done by hand cuz they're churning out
the omelets here but every one is made
by an individual guy who's taken a lot
of time to perfect it eggs not just for
babies and old people anymore we are at
the Sanrio store right now and we're
checking out one of the greatest enemy
dictators of all time gudetama ria what
is good at Thomas today it's like maybe
hired tamales from chemical Oh
entomology I'm ready to look at some
good at tie my stuff oh yes in the
airport with this thing look at that
Hey look Andrew gouda caviar do we have
good at dumbest but good eh but this
gudetama has a little bindle like he was
hitchhiking somewhere and then he just
gave up gudetama hamburger pen I'm gonna
tell my toothbrush
gudetama lanyard for my ID at work get
that FBI freeze Steven look look towards
me
thummell go mama to see the shade of
yellow or orange that an egg yolk has is
dependent upon the chickens diet however
the color of the yolk does not say
anything about the nutritious value of
the egg interesting ok typically
Japanese egg deal feeds very orange like
your a t-shirt color oh yeah that's
totally why award today I want yellow to
just I left out Oh popcorn good it
telephone
oh it's of it you see the counter oh wow
God is quick to be lazy well good at
that my son
oh wow now we have a snack for the train
because we're on our way to Kyoto have a
very special egg dish
[Music]
[Music]
watashi wa Yukimura motor Kitty listen
um I was that eyo Sakuya ticket what
type of restaurant is this Bioshock una
no there Feyenoord Hamburg lemma omurice
day but Anna neon there guy coca record
a high ticket atmosphere tomorrow yone
sorry God or syncope day Doka Doka no my
feminine update the money they take
kokyunage or adapt and ska Domo America
Cara catch up to your mana hi there
chiming no Hornet doing her all that
picked up do you know what you're so
cool
this man this morning really hey no no
no go ahead you okay what separates your
omurice from the original recipe so I
understand that it's typically made with
ketchup ketchup
alright first demo c'mon mark on the
other you don't have my fun picking
different even know what I see you know
so could eat a hot day
what they mean is also a G dip Emily
it's almost a very AutoStick
they would have thought they'd take your
flute today putting the armor on top how
does that enhance the taste of the dish
hello honey I believe Cara NGO community
normally meet they are sorry to talk
some today with unilateral dinner ready
yeah
mother no skin died so to creamer canary
Co veto such the speedo
Knopf cetera hey okay sorry ma Coco got
big little did I know to do it then
DiMaggio change last person sorry Cara
Maria Teresa de mama you know knock our
Honda cool Maria it's my inner Akita
who's sweet
tamagoyaki knees knocking about always
good night
ready ready make it sing
more MORE good conduits by actor Tom Tom
Tom hey me nothing
Tom Tom yoni Lucas no more tyranny come
on this guy Somnath SUNYAC I need king
Dyson or you know sit there I thought
she was giving them wha
you don't do this yeah okay you can yeah
the way that you make this omurice er is
very theatrical
what do you think that yeah look laughs
the audio fluid today okay come on
you're you me oh the audio pterin unit
you may always show by that - you told
me is your siren dammit yo yo cetera
Duncan was [ __ ] overnight you will not
enjoy suru koto de dun da heat hi
Catherine sorry Dougy Quixote Cudicini
not be do you think that the theatre
helps the food tastes better
what's wrong of course la moto moto
Tunisia who knows you know enjoy
Shannara do that screw
[Music]
ox times to particular number one this
is the number one day yeah almost famous
number ah number one number one yeah I
love it
yeah so we're taking a little detour
from eggs because this is part of the
process of making a demitasse it's the
same base but different ratio for beef
stock okay and it's similar for 96 hours
so I'm gonna taste the sauce first yeah
Cheers
did that give us hmm
holy crow I need another one because
that was too complicated to understand
on the first bite this is like
unsweetened chocolate syrup style of
bitterness it's very delicious tongue is
one of the most underrated meats can
come off a little scary because it's the
tongue yeah anything is part of
something's expression is scary to eat
but it tastes good wow that's wonderful
that itself well so soft Adam actually
loves chung more than everybody on this
show
oh boy little taste of the Deming laws
and now the main event
oh yeah oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
full disclosure being this before it
never gets old
no every time it puts a smile on your
face it's like Disneyland exactly mas
you did a game on not having to chew is
a luxury here at the restaurant they
only have spoons available because
that's all you're gonna need huh the egg
is almost like an icing for this rice
but the textures are still distinct and
interact with each other very well you
know it's not just one creamy steak the
genetic well the magic of this dish it's
really the happy body watching him make
this dish he's having fun he's been
making this for many years to do
something over and over and over again
and still have the same joy is
incredible and I get to be a part of
that what is your secret you have this
amazing energy this friendly disposition
aura and that I got another note all of
them what I'm gonna hop you know we'll
do that what I'm happy depends on the
customer by you guys are also very
excited and he kind of absorbing your
happiness so that makes him happy that's
actually a very good lesson how to be
happy can't do it by yourself you have
happiness my happiness oh no your
happiness my happiness this is very
delicious thank you so much thank you
we're here in Kyoto and I wanted to have
a little sweet treat to round out the
day we a recommended that we come up
here we are here in March a house I love
this place my traits my favorite flavor
you to arrive Andrew you're trying magic
Jamison and Stephen you are having puffs
a parfait is my favorite pizza I already
had 2 or 3 affairs through my trip
already
it's anybody looking for puffy
ambassador they should choose me oh oh
look at how it only lava was it so yeah
shut up and put the much in your mouth
isn't it creamy
sure let me see you've ever have yeah
it's so good alright parfait part a
parfait the matcha is so smooth here
come on Mizuki
in the Oh wha Kidani Valley or great
boiling valley there's a certain egg
delicacy known as glue roto Mago famous
for their black exterior that develops
from being boiled in volcanic water ray
have you ever heard of this I just told
the reate something about eggs in Japan
that's the beauty of the egg fact
everybody learned something egg fact
really I'm ready to be your parfait
apprentice yes maybe a Terra me too I'm
a sous-chef yeah Terra me sous-chef yeah
okay that does it on Kyoto off to
Chichibu
[Music]
too much in Arizona
Akua policy with the most affectionate
icono I like the least of this you're
just gonna die touching on this I know
it's his eyes totally muscle kayak - you
should know come on oh oh gosh oh gosh I
see tax day to me what makes this egg so
special it's to understand they're gonna
come out on it - oh cool it's gonna keep
getting Latino Kodomo Landers I didn't
know Coco Chanel skiddo
I don't put a Sun side risotto kini boku
no tama what's good tic-tac-toe kotatsu
they do no more time about screwing the
other bad curry want any holy I don't
know what's gonna I talked to Monte she
there
Scott across it go to Coney cuz i a Kiki
time ago I thought I know you don't know
khaki acid it's good that olena know the
capital Dawkins image the demons know
they're pretty shiny crystal if they
want to kill the snake so what is how
old you know original that's to do good
tomorrow if I ate a NGO Jones a stable
come over America just told me to
connect communities Godot as you got no
corn and as you know cosa got there
Oh mommy daddy and it's the yolk color
unique hundred oh no kidding a whole
lemon
and on your way was kidding do I have to
get it over spicy nine lenient avataric
are either skied all the authority Emeka
tinnitus to come up when you are sort of
- I like you know ducky this how do you
think this egg is best sir number the
Arabic Allah never like you money I'm
pushing there we should why is it that
in Japan you can eat eggs raw give me it
you need if you own Coco God keep you
seen this skinny guys implicate items
which came first the chicken or the egg
balloon watch out that I'm a longer
darling that make sense yeah
we're now back in Tokyo the eggs took a
little train ride with us so what are we
gonna be eating today react
it's called tamago kake Gohan we call it
pkg tamago egg cockades / Gohan's rice
Thank You sake for the okay damn uncle
got gay Gohan tamago kake Gohan we did a
better ba it's pretty I think it's a tie
look at this this is like how nice
bottle of champagne usually gnomes this
egg name is karai Aki kebaya keeps like
sharing his son's name is Hikaru also
same Kanji character mmm his son was
like when am I gonna get an egg yeah
he's like alright not that open let's
get this TKG RTG what that mean
ready to go okay
[Music]
thank you so you just crack egg on top
of the rice few drops of soy sauce mix
with it and enjoy my heart is racing
because I don't want to mess this up
it's like when you take thousands of
free-throws
I've cracked thousands of eggs in my
life preparing for this one moment
cheers Stephen James nice
Wow look at that no orange the yolk is
very impressive but the white has so
much structural integrity on its own
look at that Oh like a ball a white
doesn't normally look like this
no my Tonto
come on a raisin bullet no oh oh oh my
goodness oh the color is getting even
richer it looks like I put ketchup on
this rice you do not it is that you miss
that's Wow so rich it tastes like an egg
based dessert it's really bitter a yeah
I really like the texture of it it's not
like a sauce right it's kind of like a
custard that easily mix it with your
rice compliments to the chef
who is the chicken Adam to like to show
you how viscous this is that's the word
viscous it's like eating Tide Pods
Steven no no you know it's good because
it has an abbreviation I'm gonna be
saying this all the time I need an
abbreviation TKG yeah like I might be
mmm NBA CIA BLT oh yeah as an actual
food what I really like about TKG it's
like sushi you have a delicious
ingredient over this pallet of rice it
allows you to enjoy it the best you
possibly can
[Music]
which egg dish was the most worth it to
you at its given price point well start
with Rea today I have to say kitchy
kitchy it's almost amazing my winner is
also Kuchiki G's on the rice soup I saw
that one coming his omurice ooh is so
unique to himself I think it's a dish
that you could travel from the other
side of the world for eg eg omurice it's
not whether that's a threeway chichi
chichi yeah matter fest I mean come on
come on come on
Adam worth it winner that's four for
omurice ooh Annie who's you're worth it
winner we have one more special Japan
location that's gonna sneak up on you in
a very unexpected way goood it diamond
ah
[Laughter]
all right bye oh yes